I am ready sir you want to do our audio
check again cuz I know how much you like
the last time oh I just imagine you just
doing like a fist pump as you do that no
I can oh I don't know how this
implicates anything do the kill
directing action hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back to a
horror story with yamimash hello ladies
and gentlemen we're back I know it's
been a while since a gmod horror map
came about but I've been busy working on
secret things that you don't need to
know about but you probably already do
how are you doing today yamimash yeah
I'm not doing too bad I'll just staring
into like the souls of the audience but
a creepy stare the whole introduced then
good keep them on I think they
appreciate oh I know they do write in
the comments below if you appreciate
yamimash is soul stare anyway since both
yamimash and I know it's gonna happen I
have no idea I'm gonna play this map
before no he's the first first 20
seconds then try it before and then
before that I accidentally spoiled some
I'm gonna go write the first joke scare
let's run together what is this place
there's actual voice acting in this one
which is pretty cool pretty cool thing
oh my god I never expected ah oh you
okay mama
hurts so bad okay carrying on alright Oh
be still my heart anyway so this one
yeah we accidentally a yamimash screwed
up huh how you also recording his audio
you always blame me yeah your audio yeah
so I had everything perfect okay anyway
so yamimash was perfect I screwed up
yeah I think there might be a jump-scare
if you got those days oh there there
couldn't be too well the chances of that
anyway so those are the this is as far
as we got before Yami has screwed up and
we had to restart so I know you might
have you don't know that okay so we need
to find a key that's what we discovered
but now it's all new territory cry boy
on the floor why do you like it hey yeah
oh cool can we wait why can't we use it
I don't know it's very hard on tink you
look at this as a crowbar other for next
to some boxes and it you can't destroy
them how does that feel nauseous I think
we're supposed to use this to pry the
wood off the doors down below some nuts
yes that I can't move very well with
this thing novice can you carry this
it's a bit of a burden okay I'm fine
when you move forward it's now Oh
horrible ting ting ting oh we gotta
break the lock with that why are we such
idiots at the lock it's over this way
I'll lead the way do I have to carry
this man yes you do because our audience
would get sick during it I feel nauseous
mark okay good
throw up on someone else I'll throw up
on Jeff yeah over here all right right
there oh I'm very intelligent it's so
strong a navigator you doesn't work now
have you guys I gave it
yeah I've been to the gym like a long
did you see that ghosty goo that was
waving at us
no that's very cute it was adorable
leave out Mavis - okay so anyway moving
forward hey let I don't think they can
see this big red mark on my head but I
think I banged my forehead last night oh
hello you you're whispering yeah they're
trying to talk to us Mac try tell each
other Jerry what say that with a little
more enthusiasm am I the only one who
hears the whispering oh no my best
friend has died this is terrible Oh No
whatever shall I do with my life
Oh do your best Shakespeare I've done
Shakespeare before you do Shakespeare
where Arthur markup I Romeo Wow
you know you think being from Britain
lands you'd be better at that than you
were oh you try
romi mash we're art through das yonder
window break yeah that's a lot better
yeah your ass does stick out of yonder
window the moon is full my bad Moony ass
yeah yeah I'm oh I wonder I I love this
commentary I like it I like it he's got
he's got oh no oh no
ha ha oh you stop oh let's move a chair
for you Oh top Jack good Hodge
oh no I'm turning into a ghost ah ok
there we all right so there's a piece of
paper we were forced to leave our homes
combines released a lot of headcrabs
into the subway area because of an
emergency they said too much enthusiasm
ah oh we are being moved somewhere else
I think but why didn't they move us
already I think they are having problems
that matter did you like that yeah that
was much better
I heard a noise it's like musics just
I'm playing yeah
what's going on yeah this is very very
peculiar only enough that is tying back
to the actual half life story with the
combine so this actually is related to
that
oh wow that's interesting but you've
never played the game so you don't know
hey I played 10 minutes of it once yeah
but that's not the game what's not here
oh no it's not again hey there's nothing
donated Ark okay why is it here you know
I've always wanted what I wanted
somebody to play music behind me
wherever I go
I like a try on a guitar or something oh
how about a string quartet that sits on
your back and just plays it whenever a
monster's nearby
Oh it'll be amazing Oh it'd be more than
amazing this one guy was in the gym on
the card hook on the treadmill and he
had a whole band doing the rocky theme
it was amazing Oh [ __ ] rocky it was
a rocky oh I bet he fouled by Rocky
after that yeah maybe okay so what is
the run in circle yeah I know I'm trying
to find we're a bit stuck but I don't
know where we're supposed to go huh
maybe should throw a charity door I'd
always look yeah that hearkens wait I
wonder if anybody remembers that
reference we were actually just
reminiscing about that way yonder long
ago
I had a tear in my eye you had a tear in
your eye Tia oh dear okay yes um are you
going that way I'll go this way
okay me gee we split up we figure it out
yeah turn into a ghost with your special
power that makes you fly through walls
if you can I have to fart remember today
yeah i Renault I remember oh I remember
you should he remember that ha ha ha oh
oh you do it already coming back it
seems like a dead end
come over here ha ha area the great
farting ghosts coming at you yeah up no
nothing in here oh hey Reba
feed me some beans yeah thank you that's
good I just ate it too I know old beans
makes you fun oh man
ok ok over there huh ah they were
supposed to go this way oh gosh
hello the hell happened there I honest
it I'm really sad uh-huh what are they
oh okay no that wasn't invisible walls
pretty sure okay back on track not
laying must've sent some food those are
combine vehicles why and I combine
vehicles wait what do you call cars in
Britain um cos oh yeah okay I thought
you'd call them like driving Wiggly
wobbles something along those lines
oh that's what we call motorbikes that
wouldn't make sense they do wibble
wobble a bit more that's funny cool huh
exactly if you ever come to angle
and you look into Rena mo by a KO whoa
damn it all it has is these screamers go
up to your nearest rental company and
ask for a wobbly whip what I call it a
wobbly Waverly Magoo okay yeah that hey
there was a kid who did that yeah dude
he's showing us the way
oh it's over here I really appreciate
the kindness of these people on this
game he is such a nice guy a clown can
that stop please huh
Madonna's for [ __ ] oh but a no-good
name is said let's can we just stop and
appreciate the immense thought that went
into this joke here I said they call
this idea from that draw my thing where
I stick a banana and ass you remember
that no I don't what not really oh that
yeah yeah that we don't talk about that
anymore
but anyway yeah great joke good job
we're gonna stick to our highbrow humor
this is aji get lo beans ma we have to
cross out the coca-cola yeah ready yeah
aw sorry I just had some access y'all
meet a fart look wait I'm doing it wrong
whoa oh there you go you go you good you
good
ah okay moving on see that's the
difference between lowbrow humor and
highbrow humor such as ours
sophisticated I think some might call it
yeah fine building well get it getting
dark there's lots of buildings which one
do we need to find one oh maybe this one
oh maybe the one over there I got an
itch shut up
there is something going on my uncle
didn't show up in the store I just hope
we didn't enter the subway we can no
longer be other night combines are
watching the street all the time I don't
know what is going to happen oh sorry I
don't know what is going to happen oh
yeah there we go okay all right um
but it's some goddess write a page of
this diary leave around the city like
what is that huh some [ __ ] here's a
clue e box on the keyboard key on the
keyboard right oh yeah I'm eating it
did anything happen is it working for
you I'm eating it hard I'm giving it to
e if you know what I mean and I was
asking for it hasn't gone e let me go I
have an e la you mash you mention yeah e
that get Korea you know so cool yeah
more you hate yeah get it real good
JP it get good oh yeah uh-huh yeah okay
hair docile I hurt someone to hear that
something happened after a good Ian you
need you know you need a release yeah oh
this is dead ed uh II I'm eating it yeah
these are you don't Evo not woman yeah
these walls don't need to be he'd yeah
what about the code is the code is much
yeah that's what the code is the code
books to any door in any love
Oh see here's a see my mom come here
what here
what well it's a thingy where are you
are a work follow me where's what's
going there you only read for you a cat
jumped over a wall and fell into a hole
and met a small mole so the code is yes
yes yeah SOE and see right yeah ECS so
that works real good on this number
panel haha he drinks you David you son
of a [ __ ] did you see that rule uh-oh
not see it like physically you know did
you give it to the wall
well I didn't really give it to it I
mean I could do it looked like it didn't
need you know it been through a lot not
giving any affection yeah let me just
check the other room F so though ii ii
ii CFS you CFS that's right
oh they're numbers uh they're all
closely alpha ecfs this is pretty
fire in the oven shut up no it's nots
backwards - okay okay wait oh yeah whoa
I don't know if that's right he is five
cs3 uh-huh f is ABCDEF to six and s is a
pretty big one huh five three six - hey
look at work yeah Wow who didn't know
who - no that would work
Wow did you catch yeah what we are on
the same wavelength right now mark we
are indeed we are you know it's because
of our long history of doing these maps
together that we have become so good at
them
we have become 100 wait I get them why
do I keep getting them why don't you get
that in front of me well I'm god what a
different direction from you he never
liked a lot of ages ago that was two
seconds ago oh that was ages ago but
also two seconds ago I was like a pair
of glasses look for a different end
trance what's wrong with this one ha ha
ha ha
I'm not taking too kindly to its
treatment of me I think we should spend
a couple minutes actually trying to
figure out this puzzle rather than
flying through the Americas or maybe I'm
already doing that that's what I'm doing
are you following me I mean okay there's
a lot of boarded up doors ah I wish I
that crow bow the dead end
no jump-scare that time ray oh wow
crub are you pick it up you get the car
doctor really you get the crowbar
oh good oh no I don't know where we
don't have nah we don't exactly have a
lock to break with that one but alright
I need to close my eyes while doing this
you just tough it through okay make a
left forward make a right make a left
right left now left [ __ ] no get back
here where this wait go through there
Ram it in oh okay that didn't work
there's got to be somewhere else that we
need to put this
Jesus you gonna okay Carol I'll take
I'll take it I'll take over just drop it
I'll get it okay
Oh God oh if I walk back oh if I walk
backwards it's much better you stupid
you didn't even think the one cyclist
and you won't get jumpscared if I'm
walking backwards Marv what about this
door what about that door it looks
different that one yeah then what we
came from I have no idea maybe Oh yep it
is
ah oh yeah we never actually opened that
one son I'm just looking around of mine
mean there's nothing over here all right
MA let's get back to the barricade I
want to eat some beans of you real quick
okay I got a spare can in my pocket oh
wait a minute hang on get that crowbar
I'm an idea ah damn it
oh no I'll get it I'll get it okay okay
okay okay what's this I'm a genius
because you failed to notice that this
particular wall of bricks was a
different color
oh no way dog bark so smart if I Hey
look we got ask Larry smart Murr woo Hey
what is it that I don't know it's it oh
it's a key it's a lever two levels of
the door Oh God okay we actually solved
the puzzles hmm who everyone believed in
us immensely
Oh any good church junk good job now you
get one oh okay you just got the
Friendly Ghost diodes give us scares
Yama you go first I am huh nothing in
here oh it's at the other okay Oh would
you look yeah there's a pile Boyd into
something it's a rental that I got it I
got right you already need a wrench
yes the well yeah yep here we go open
door open door let me try yeah all right
ah now I'll go through okay I I think it
jumps guy is gonna happen mark you're a
lying sack of crap no jumpscares gonna
get me see what'd I tell you no doctors
oh really
yeah Oh God amazed
just ah nah I'm the minute boxes - I
can't even break these but you take this
I cannot deal with that you are gonna
need yeah just leave em over there oh ha
ha you ki tear kazar page yeah if you
read that no you try this one you read
this oh okay you read this one hmm
ah why is in front of my face if you
read this you have survived the outbreak
let's at least the first ways these
things and off the subway nobody
expected that I have hidden in here but
I will need to move on
perhaps the lawns or the area the
laundry area mmm
missus a can of beans ah plus a tap plus
another canapes equals a wrench how in
the world does that make any goddamn
just say if you eat a lot of beans
you're gonna need to wrench all that
stuff outta you
I don't see a wrench anywhere in there
but I'm gonna throw this on the table
see what happens yeah my luck and oh
good job thank you thank you so much did
you see what happened I was amazing
yeah I did it was awesome oh I finally
can of paint what we need
oh yeah yeah right I can't touch him oh
you can't right yeah grab it ah what
happened in this corner yummy
what'd I do I just I needed I just got
why did I do ah oh yeah about playing
with the mayonnaise you don't do it
basically Bob came over and we was with
playing video games and then it got a
little out of hand
yeah because Bobby mash is the ultimate
ship that is that ship is sailing hard
it's like two people that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah I saw the fan art attacks did you
actually see the fan art it was ton of
it yeah that's right yeah it was it was
a surprising amount of a patient I saw
at least three um oh is this way
I found a can I got a can now good job
I didn't K&L purchase ranks if we could
just get the UH the other kind of pain I
can't seem to grab it
try and grab all of them no I tried
you're not moving maybe you got to get
the wrench um um somewhere in this maze
I would imagine uh I look around a
little bit of this I did not work what
did you do mark it didn't work it didn't
do nothing ah hey wait no I found
another can of beans
oh wait no I'm are what no what Capri
covers also this just yet Wow
oh it's room maybe you're not in this
room maybe it's outside this room maybe
you're outside this room
I would imagine it's all the way down
there yeah yeah whoa good job hey your
pictures on this wall I see you're kind
of famous on the Internet at least an
entire handsome devil no you're kind of
old no Glee but that's besides the point
old and stylish more like aa pretty much
pretty sure it's ugly like gonna get in
deeper Andy but oh I was just about to
come in on that like really come on come
on really really hmm hey stand on the
train tracks I'm sure that'll end well
okay well I'll uh ah come on Jesus not
only half killed me the last time it
happened hug Hey look shadow guy let's
go behind that door I won't go behind
there
are you sure yeah oh hello is Paige all
right try the Bain boys just for the no
though okay it's getting worse and worse
I can hear the whispers and I'm seeing
people's faces if you get to the laundry
area anyhow contact me over the radio I
need gas and we can get out of here
alone well our lambs dear are if I can't
really do the Bain voice right now my
voice isn't a hundred percent amid no
it's still very good oh you think the
main voice is your other no no no just
something
we did you think that note would stop
the babe Oh Mike you do this to me man
Oh away from me oh okay good job hey
weld all right we made it to the laundry
area
oh wow from Redrum Redrum red red red
red red room Redrum Redrum Redrum Redrum
bass thank you on the red room Oh what
the hell is in there
zombies huh that's a let's now go in the
red room
yeah the red room red roommate fun wow
your pictures all over the place you
share our famous I'm promoting my new
hair line product Wow
what you have here that's the danger huh
how's my mother that was your mother
your mother looking lovely thank you oh
we need to fix the radio somehow I bet
if I had a wrench I could do that yeah
or if you had a brick can you through it
yeah boxers that I can't break this must
be torment for you mark it's just
Absalom not again what where look at air
yeah you went the wrong way Jack please
stop being so stupid and go the correct
way
mmm all right there's nothing over here
you call me Dora the Explorer uh I don't
think that's what they call you
some people call me that who who calls
you that my mother oh isn't that sweet
this is just a big circle that we're
going in and my pet cat twinkle your pet
cat do you really have a pet cat named
twinkle no I wish I did
oh look oh look with my I'm going
through puberty voice Oh boxes came
through the ceiling boxes they really
like you today don't know apparently and
I guess I was right about my rents
theory that this radio needed a little
bit of a wrenching my heaven isn't mud
well why would you hope that I'm trying
to fix it
they don't want you to solve all the
puzzles cuz I'm gonna be jealous
yeah I've solved all of them with my big
brain tell me how big my flight is Oh
donk donk donk donk donk donk donk donk
donk hey I think I can hear something
yeah you can it's not working
oh no wait just listen closer whoa
beautiful fixing radios gives you gas
problems yeah Murphy [ __ ] ok bye the
hell hi
I want a Red Room I think the smokers
bus going the Red Room okay uh save us
some good ones so that we can get
through here in one piece all right are
you ready to let out I think the beans
are my great one let it rip then we may
have been supposed to get a gun at some
point I'm in trouble where are you I
don't know just follow the red all right
I'm following it I might be in a spot of
trouble yeah yeah not again do they look
like me do I look like then dude I am
one of them I don't know why they're
trying to kill me
hmm I think it's cuz you're like not
conforming you don't have a head crap on
you're right you're right when you're
right you're right yeah ok let's escape
you've got god mode on we can't die yeah
I know I didn't mean to have that on but
it is it is what it is fine with that
right now oh look a car ruin it run hey
there's someone dead in here oh wait
what oh so me just gonna get hit for
another six seconds oh no you can't have
my kind of beans did wait get out do ya
me did you make it yeah okay good
yay you have escaped that was awful that
was amazing oh yeah sorry that was
incredible thank you Jeff for that
music's going away
cuz that was obviously not happy free
music I have some problems that he is
that music
well once again I've drawn the short
straw on these gmod horror maps I think
we should at least analyze it for the
next 30 seconds and tell the good and
the bad about it okay good let's list
off lots of screamers oh that's a
screamers it's a scream top-notch voice
acting hmm impeccable level design that
didn't all look the same
absolutely incredible Stu subtle puzzle
clear direction knew exactly what we
were supposed to do the entire time that
we were playing we had no Brian anyway a
storyline - and at every single corner
there was the can of beans - can of
beans
they knew two people were coming through
there and they would need it beautiful
10 out of 10 loved it every second so
why would you not do it why would you
not correct why would you not that was
immense I am moved by how beautiful that
was you know I think the next one is got
a lot to live up to the next part we do
exactly yes
but that will be later because I am
going to be resting so check yummy
masses channel comes Sunday thank you
yes that's what to come out so thank you
all so much for watching thank you
yamimash for being here no problem I
always enjoy doing these were you mad
you interrupted me I was about to do my
outro and you know sorry yeah sorry good
and as always we'll see you in the next
video bye bye now this guy's creepy